ce rendez-vous il l'attendait depuis
longtemps pour le rencontrer ils ont
parcouru près de 1200 km en voiture
depuis la franche comptée mettre
à 100 m de notre hôtel et on va essayer
d'allerter sur sur une de Lou qui qui
loge non loin d'ici des photographes
passionnés de Faun sauvage juste avant
l'aube bercé par la promesse du
loup on est calme et on est rempli
d'espoir de pouvoir apercevoir à l'eau
comme ça à proximité des habitations
c'est c'est le calme avant la tempête si
jamais il se passe quelque chose bon
alors du coup vous vous installez là
vous parce que là vous êtes en face de
la zone où il est censé
sortir 3h à rester immobile et une
légère déception ce jourl le loup est
passé tout près dans les traces d'une
compagnie de sanglier et d'un renard en
maraude un loup discret un loup des
Abrus il y a la tension qui est monté un
peu sur notre droite là je sur la petite
crête on a eu la chance d'avoir pouvoir
le voir passer 2 secondes mais au moins
on revient pas bredouille pour
l'observation bredouille pour les photos
mais mais au moins on l'a vu c'est un
truc qu'on pourrait pas voir en Fran
compé ici c'est des conditions
complètement drastiquement différente
quoi on a on a pas de chasse il y a
beaucoup plus d'individus et puis euh et
puis ici les gens ont un rapport
différent avec la présence du loup donc
ça maximise les chances pour avoir des
observations
correctes les abruses le poumon vert du
centre de l'Italie un territoire
comparable au massif du Jura même si les
sommets ici dépassent facilement les
m très peu d'habitants une terre où
l'élevage et le loup cohabit depuis près
d'un
siècle c'est dans ce paysage que Piro
Romano et son épouse élèv près de 300
chèvres quand le berger redescend des
alpages le soir ce sont surtout ces
chiens
remarâurage s les chiens ça n'a pas de
sens chi lien de famille avec le
troueau que ce soit les moutons les
chèvres ou les
vaches le chien des abruses est comme ça
tu lui confies quelque chose ou un
troupeau il va le
protéger pour ce qui me concerne je ne
sors jamais sans mes
chiens 13 chiens au total des bergers
des abruses tous équipés d'un
collier ça c'est un collier antiloup
d'habitude il y a des piques en fer mais
comme on travaille beaucoup sur la
socialisation des chiens avec les hommes
on a vu que cétait dangereux surout à
hauteur des
ENF on a donc étudier une forme
alternative pour que le chien soit
toujours
protégé c'est très léger pour l'animal
très résistant comme le loup attaque
toujours au cou cela évite la mort du
chien pour doper ses chiens Piro ne line
pas sur la nourriture des pâes 2 € par
jour et par
chien cela ne coûte pas cher si on
considère qu'en 2 ans on a pas eu une
seule prédation le coup du chien passe
au second
plan si en un jour je perds une chèvre
je la perds vraiment mais ça n'arrive
pas avec les
[Musique]
chiens si le loup se fait discret au
quotidien son image est en revanche
omniprésente dans les abruses on plus
les restaurants ou les hôtels à son nom
ici le loup n'est pas un ennemi plutôt
une mascotte qui fait tourner l'économie
au même titre que l'ours l'autre grand
prédateur installé lui aussi dans le
[Musique]
paysage c'est que du
bonheur les gens ici ils viennent de
partout pour voir notre
territoire
et l' ours il y a du
monde et sans eux on travaille
pas au pays de Romulus etus on ne
critique pas le loup dans le centre du
petit village de
citella on peut même observer quelques
spécim blessés la convalescence avant la
liberté et juste à côté un
musée
ce musée est le premier entièrement
dédié au LOU en
Europe les gens ont commencé à venir
grâce à la promotion faite par le
parc tout s fait petit à petit les gens
voulaient voir les loups en
semiberté le tourisme et
l'élevage de pili de l'économie du
massif un système largement contrôlé par
le parc national des
abruses Mara Gagliardi est l'une des 35
gardes du
parc son rôle conseiller les éleveurs
ici le loup a déjà attaqué plusieurs
fois il a fallu
s'adapter la période la plus dangereuse
c'est à la naissance des veau ça dure 10
ou 15 jours pendant lesquels les
TR on a choisi la race limousine parce
est plus agressive quand il le faut
est-ce que vous tirez sur des meut vous
iciè dans les par c'est
complètement sur auun
anim le LOU fait partie de notre
culture on chasse
pas alors il faudrait aussi chasser
l'oursenout pas
mal
tous les agriculteurs bien sûr ne
tiennent pas ce type de discours parfois
des bergers se vengent empoisonne
quelques loups récemment une ours bien
connue dans le parc et souvent filmé par
les touristes a été tué d'un coup de
fusil le chasseur ne sort plus de chez
lui un geste impardonnable qui a fait la
une des journaux mais en Italie la
diplomatie reste une
priorité j'aime pas
trop de parler des pouvoir parce que
notre notre GO c'est la
coexistance plusieurs fois par mois les
gardes font le point sur la centaine de
loup et la cinquantaine d'ours présent
dans le
parc ils étaient là ce matin on a vu
DESC de
Louette
Pr des ABR assure le remboursement des
éleveurs et ce dans un délai de 3
mois pour des bovins ou des chevaux on
paye entre 1000 et 1200 € pour une seule
tête si elle est inscrite au registre de
la
race sinon on rembourse beaucoup moins
ça dépend des cas mais ça peut aller
jusqu'à 1100 € pour un veau de quelques
jours parce que là on tient compte de la
sélection
[Musique]
le conseil qu'on pourrait donner à nos
cousins français c'est que ce qu'on fait
ici
fonctionne mais il faut du
temps et surtout il faut changer
l'imaginaire sur le
loup éviter ces fake news cette idée que
le loup tue à grèe
détruit année après année on a construit
une image terrible du LOU il faut parler
du LOU dans les écoles préparer le
terrain là où il n'existe pas
encore les habitants des abruses ont
choisi la voie du milieu celle de la
cohabitation avec le loup alors qu'en
Europe d'autres pays souhaiteraient
durcir la législation autour du grand
prédateur